today on the mat well show black lives
matter is a far-left political group
with far left political goals it's
really that simple it's not concerned at
all with preserving black life we're
gonna talk about that today we're gonna
talk about what black lives matters
actual agenda is because I think that's
important also five headlines including
mentally unbalanced college students
saying that they are too traumatized to
return to school because one of the
students at the school tweeted a joke
about George Floyd and now they're too
scared to go back this is real we'll
talk about that and some Jimmy John's
employees were fired for making an
allegedly racist video the only problem
is that there's nothing racist in the
video at all yet they've been fired
anyway and smeared as racist so all of
that on the way but before we get to
anything else the show today is brought
to you by our friends at LifeLock you
know having your identity stolen it's
not just a sort of a scary experience
it's also a huge hassle if you've ever
been through this to try to get it to
try to undo the damage cyber criminals
are not going to let the Cova 19 crisis
stop them from using tax fraud to take
what is not theirs what doesn't belong
to them with the extension of the tax
filing date to July 15th
there's expected to be a rise in
tax-related identity through identity
fraud the types of tax related fraud
vary but remember the IRS will not
contact you directly by email or text
message or other online platforms so if
you get something like that it's it's
gonna be an identity thief thief
identity thieves are getting smarter all
the time and as you know as people learn
about one scheme while they're just
hatching another scheme now that's why
you need comprehensive protection
especially during tax season when so
much of your most vital private
information is being shared that's why
it's so great that life lock is there
life lock is a leader in identity theft
protection life lock detects a wide
range of identity theft threats and
they're gonna like your social security
number being for sale on the dark web
whatever it is and they're gonna alert
you to that and take care of it remember
no one can prevent all identity theft or
monitor all transactions at all
businesses life lock and see threats
that you might miss on your own so join
now and save 25% on your first year go
to life lock coms last Walsh
LifeLock dot-com / walls for 25% off ok
alleged news anchor Don Lemon had a
pretty fascinating exchange with Terry
Crews last night on his alleged news
program Terry Crews is an actor TV TV
host TV personality also black man who
has had the courage to speak out in
recent weeks about the real threats that
are faced by the black community a
Cruz's point has been that the police
are not the main problem by a long shot
if we're gonna talk about black lives
matter we need to talk about all of the
black victims of violence most of whom
are victims of violence perpetrated by
other black men that's the reality now
Don Lemon doesn't like that he doesn't
want to talk about that Don Lemon is is
generally opposed to integrity and
intellectual courage in all its forms so
if he sees that he's gonna have a
problem with it especially now so here
is a lemon
explaining his point of view really it
should be Terry Crews explaining his
point of view because he's the one on
for the interview but instead it's Don
Lemon explaining his point of view and
it's extremely revealing I think listen
to this the black lives matter movement
was started because it was talking about
police brutality if you want an all
black lives matter movement that talks
about gun violence in communities
including you know black communities
then start that movement with that name
but that's not what black lives matter
is about it's not an all encompassing so
if you're talking about if someone
started moving that said cancer matters
and then someone comes and said why are
you talking about HIV it's not the same
thing we're talking about cancer so the
black lives matter movement is about
police brutality and injustice in that
manner not about what's happening in
black neighborhoods if you there are
people who are working on that issue and
if you want to start that issue why
don't you started do you understand what
I'm saying
but would you but when you look at their
organization police brutality is not the
only thing they're talking about
know that I agree but that's not what
the black lives matter movement is about
Terry black lives matters about police
brutality and abroad and about criminal
justice it's not about what happens in
communities when it comes to crime black
on black crime people who live near each
other black people kill each other
same as White's 80 some percent of white
people are killed by white people
because of proximity it's the same thing
with black people it happens in every
single neighborhood but that doesn't
again I'm not saying that's not
important that those those kids died but
it's a different movement Lemon seems to
really be struggling there with the
concept of an interview because normally
an interview is a thing where you ask
questions to the interviewee and then
you give him a chance to answer that's
what the interview is supposed to be
instead lemon pontificates and then
continues pontificating even as the
interview per interviewee is trying to
respond that's the way lemon handles us
no wonder CNN's ratings have taken a
dive ever since people stopped going to
airports you know because they didn't
have the captive audience anymore
who would ever actually choose to watch
this in their own home on their own time
that's the that's what I don't
understand but what he says there is
illustrative I think he actually says
now you heard it for yourself I'm not
exaggerating this isn't hyperbole or
misquoting he actually says that black
lives matter does not mean all black
lives matter actually says that so so
forget all lives matter we know we're
not supposed to say that it isn't even
all black lives matter according to Don
Lemon it's only about the very very very
small percentage of black people who are
killed by police that's all we're
talking about they're the ones we're
supposed to be focused on according to
Don Lemon now the problem for Lemon is
that BLM has a website where it outlines
its mission statement and the things
that it's concerned about and fighting
for its guiding beliefs and principles
and what you find there is an extremely
wide range of issues not just police
brutality let's say that that is not the
exclusive focus of black lives matter at
all
it also by the way
says all black lives matter it
identifies that as one of its guiding
principles from the website it says we
are guided by the fact that all black
lives matter direct quote from BLM's
website so contra Lemon BLM does in fact
claim that it's it is representing all
black lives and it's fighting for all
black lives it now it doesn't actually
do that not even close but it does claim
that that is its mission and its
motivation and that's the point that
Terry Crews and many others are trying
to make if you let them speak without
talking over them if you say black lives
matter and you say that's what you're
fighting for
then what about all these black lives
over here these lives that are being
destroyed on a daily basis how can you
ignore them if you're fighting for all
black lives at least five children were
killed just this past weekend in our
cities I think actually it was six
children
an eight-year-old was killed in Atlanta
shot while she was in her car a
thirteen-year-old was killed in a
carjacking in in California
sixteen-year-old was shot in the face in
Rochester more than a dozen other people
were shot in Rochester over the weekend
nine people were shot in Baltimore 69
were shot 16 killed in Chicago 25 were
shot in Atlanta this is all in one
weekend one weekend of activity
thousands of black people are murdered
every year and in some weekends as we
see you know you have dozens in a span
of 24 hours of 48 hours over 7,000 black
people were killed in the year 2018 for
example and black people are murdered at
a rate six times higher according to DOJ
statistics black people are murdered at
a rate six times higher than white
people six times but over 90% of those
murders are carried out by people in
their own communities and of their own
race that's the reality and it is just
absolute height of absurdity and
fraudulence to have a black lives matter
movement that ignores all of this
especially when you consider all of the
other things besides police brutality
that BLM focuses on and we're gonna I
want to go through some of those things
in just a second but before we do I want
to tell you about some new sponsors
we're very excited about on the show
blink sale you know the quintessential
American dream is owning and building a
successful business but as many business
owners know there are so many moving
parts so many things going on it can be
hard to manage everything and still stay
on track doing what you love and doing
what you need to do to run your business
a big part of that is invoicing you know
have you ever had to hassle a client
that owed you money or gotten lost
trying to keep track of your hidden
voices and payments maybe you just made
a basic template in Microsoft Word and
you hate how ugly it is and how sort of
clunky and difficult it to use it is
that's why you need blank sale they have
built an invoicing software that helps
you stay on top of your money keep track
of everything in one place so you can
stop sending those nagging emails to get
you paid for your work it's just a lot
easier this way I mean with blink sale
you can send beautiful custom branded
invoices and estimates and seconds you
can stay on top of your outstanding
invoices you can let your customers and
clients easily pay for your invoices
online you're leaving it instant
notifications with a customer opens your
invoice and so you'll know that that
that they actually did see it
so forget about using invoice templates
or stressing about coordinating a bunch
of different software programs blink
sale takes care of all of that for you
and and you know the main thing for me
is you don't have the awkwardness of
saying the emails over and over and over
again that's the best part as an added
bonus blink sales giving away ten
dollars to five hundred daily wire fans
here's how to get it go to blink sale
comm start your 14-day free trial
create your first invoice of ten dollars
and activate an online payment option
stripe or PayPal then you send the
invoice to daily wire at blink sale comm
and you get paid your ten dollars the
first five hundred people to send an
invoice for ten dollars to Delhi wire at
komm will get their invoice paid by
Blink sale there's a limit of one per
person stop wasting time and invoicing
and try blink sale for free at blink
sale calm slash Walsh that's be Li NK s
al e comm slash Walsh blink sale spend
less time billing and more time doing
what you love okay so BLM let me read
their mission state to mission statement
to you okay right right from their
website it says we are guided by the
fact that all black lives matter
regardless of actual or perceived sexual
identity gender identity gender
expression economic status ability
disability religious beliefs or
disbeliefs immigration status or
location we make space for transgender
brothers and sisters to participate and
lead we are self reflexive and do the
work required to dismantle cisgender
privilege and uplift black trans folks
especially black trans women who
continue to be disproportionately
impacted by trans antagonistic violence
we build a space that affirms black
women and is free from sexism misogyny
and environments in which men are
centered we practice empathy we engage
comrades with the comrades actually say
comrades we engage comrades with the
intent to learn about and connect with
their contexts to learn about and
connect with their contexts you know I
just want to connect with your context
that sounds vaguely sexual doesn't it it
sounds very euphemistic we make our
spaces family-friendly and enable
parents to fully participate with their
children we dismantle the patriarchal
practice that requires mothers to work
double shifts so that they can mother in
private even as they participate in
public justice work we disrupt the
Western proscribed nuclear family
structure by supporting each other as
extended families and villages that
collectively care for one another we
foster a queer affirming network when we
do we we do so with the intention of
freeing our
elves from the tight grip of
heteronormative thinking or rather the
belief that all in the world are
heterosexual we cultivate an
intergenerational and communal network
free from ageism we believe that all
people regardless of age show up with
the capacity to lead and learn okay so
and that's just that's just part of it
okay so we're talking about trans people
we're talking about actually probably an
awful lot about trans people for some
reason we're talking about sexism we're
talking about the patriarchy we're
talking about unfair working conditions
we're talking about ageism we're talking
about disrupting the nuclear family
we're talking about getting rid of
heteronormative thinking we're talking
about cisgender privilege and then
elsewhere on the website it also says
they're focused on environmental
injustice economic injustice access to
health care access to quality education
voting rights voter suppression sounds
like 14 things I think 14 or 15 and
that's just a sampling it is a veritable
cornucopia of issues that they are
talking about mostly far-left issues
often extremely far-left issues
dismantling the nuclear family
heteronormative thinking this is far far
far far left a bunch of stuff that you'd
expect you know a white girl in a gender
studies class to care about if you
polled the average black person in
America if you got a you know if you had
a thousand black people pulled it random
do you think that they would cite these
as high priorities in their lives are
these the things they're waking up
worried about and focused on cisgender
privilege and heteronormative thinking
did the average black person view if you
were to ask them well you know what
about what are the things that most
important you how many are gonna say
dismantling cisgender privilege
the average white person's gonna answer
that way the answer is almost none
now I haven't conducted this poll but I
that that's that's that's I think a very
fair assumption because these are the
goals and and desires and priorities of
far-left political activists and yet
amid all of these issues despite the
extremely wide lens that BLM is is using
here they can't make room anywhere on
the website to even mention the problem
of black children being slaughtered in
the street by criminals they've got time
to talk about cisgender privilege yet
somehow cisgender privilege is a is a is
a bigger affront to black lives and to
the dignity of black life than black
children being killed in the street and
carjackings they have no space for that
they have no space for the thousands of
other black people who are killed every
year they don't mention it doesn't come
up anywhere ever the sad fact of the
matter is that black lives matter is a
very necessary message because black
lives are indeed devalued and discarded
on a routine basis in this country but
that devaluing and that discarding is
happening almost all of the time in the
vast vast majority of cases within the
black community itself there is no
getting around that
and the murder rate is not the only
evidence of that I want you to watch
this video I'm gonna play this for you
and it's gone sort of viral over the
past few days it's actually from I think
2019 and it shows a young black guy with
two other young black people in the car
one of them his sister apparently and
then someone else and he's flaunting his
guns and he's saying that he's gonna
kill a cop if he gets pulled over just
just watch this
let's do the Jake flight and I go my
sister I will kill her you know as well
let me go do the hill you know you
better I will kill you
okay no think about what you just saw
there that that is a young guy who is
apparently totally willing to throw his
own life away for no reason
he's according to his own words he is
prepared to die for no reason he's ready
to shoot at a cop instigate a fatal
encounter
the best-case scenario go to jail for
the rest of his life for no reason just
you know why not no reason other than
bravado and acting out the stuff that he
hears in songs like the one that's
playing in the background during the
video black lives matter
yeah they do but tell him that he
doesn't know that that guy and now I'm
sure he would shout the slogan but he
doesn't even think his own life matters
his own life he is this is a a
self-imposed devaluing of his own life
that he is doing he's willing to die
just because just to impress some people
on Instagram or Facebook whoever that
video was was streaming this is the same
attitude the Rashard Brooks had he he
instigated a fatal encounter with cops
for just why yeah because he didn't want
to go to jail for because you know he
was he was gonna go to jail for DUI
okay well now now best case scenario
you've just you've just gone from your
getting a DUI charge to about seven
other felony charges that's best case
scenario if you survive which he didn't
that's Ray chard Brooks who did not
think his own life mattered certainly
not enough to to take basic steps to
preserve his own life and this is the
attitude that cops in the city run up
against all the time it is a very
noxious and virulent kind of nihilism
which treats violence and even death as
a game and this is what cops are
confronting in the inner cities across
the country if your black lives matter
movement is if you're the cops are
confronting us if your black lives
matter movement is not confronting this
and not addressing it and not fighting
against it and not exposing it then your
black lives matter movement is nothing
but a fraud nothing but a front which is
what BLM is now I want you to imagine
just think about for a moment the
situation that a the average black child
in in this in a in you know the average
inner city is facing okay
he's growing up in a home without a
father he listens to music and consumes
media that explicitly glorifies and
advocates violence murder and crime in
you know of course it's like it's cliche
to even talk about that or cliche but
also I guess racist to talk about that
or you know it's offensive somehow but
this is the stuff that kids in the city
not just in the city across the country
but listening to is it openly advocating
say oh yeah go out get yourself killed
so no father in the home consuming media
that explicitly glorifies navigates
violence crime and murder living in a
community where murder murder is a daily
occurrence in Chicago it is a daily
occurrence in Baltimore it's a daily
occurrence drug dealers rule the streets
that's the situation he's in what honest
person
could look at that and decide that the
police are the biggest problem you you
really think for that black child that
the biggest problem for him is the
police that's where all this goes back
that's the source of most of his
troubles that's the thing most likely to
kill him no not even close so the whole
thing is ludicrous and it is it's a
shame that you know that there is that
there is something called the black
lives matter movement that doesn't
actually care about black lives because
we could we could use a real black lives
matter movement
let's go to headlines so a couple weeks
ago a student at Kansas State Jaden
McNeil tweeted a joke about George Floyd
the tweet said congratulations to George
Floyd on being drug-free for an entire
month okay that was the joke edgy joke
okay it's the kind of thing that at the
absolute most a joke like that warrants
a sort of a hey man too soon or
something like that at least that's how
normal sane well-adjusted mentally
balanced adults respond to offensive
jokes whoa hey that's the most that an
offensive joke should ever get out of
you whoa
like that and then you move on with your
life and you forget about it because
hopefully there are I mean quite
literally a billion other things in your
life that are more important to you than
the joke that you just heard or saw on
Twitter but we happen to live in a
country that is home to lots of people
who are not saying not well-adjusted and
not mentally balanced and this is doubly
triply quadruple II true in in our
colleges so this tweet provoked an
enormous reaction with students
panicking over it and the administration
of the school treating it well just just
look at these statements that were
frantically sent out by the
administration on the day of the tweet
the day of the tweets the day that will
live in infamy because of the tweet
this is Thomas Lane Dean of Students
this is what he said for those impacted
by this incident please know they're our
supportive resources available including
the Office of Student Life Counseling
Services and k-state diversity okay
this sounds like there was a school
shooting that that supportive resources
for those impacted that's the kind of
thing you hear after a shooting but
there was no shooting nobody was killed
nobody was injured
nothing happened to anybody nobody was
hurt in any way whatsoever there was a
tweet what would even what would it even
sound like to go and seek resources
because of a tweet I just want to know
what that that exchange when a student
goes into the Office of Student Life
like what are they saying yes hi I uh I
saw the tweet please help please help me
I saw the tweet I saw the tweet
something like that I imagine and then
here's a message from the school
president a message from President
Richard Mayer says the insensitive
comments posted by one k-state student
hurts our entire community these
divisive statements do not represent the
values of our University we condemn
racism and bigotry in all its forms
we're launching an immediate review of
the university's options black lives
matter at Kansas State University and we
will continue to fight for social
justice hurts the community how exactly
can you explain that one Pres I mean
it's in specific detail I want you to
walk me through the steps okay step one
somebody tweets a joke about George
Floyd and then there are a few more
steps and then someone is hurt like what
what happens it how how does that tweet
become a thing that is hurting someone
and in what way are they hurt by it
that's what I want to understand also by
the way why is it just as soon
that this is racist it's yeah it's it's
it's a it's an attack against an
individual named George Floyd you could
say it's it's in poor taste you could
you could use all kinds of different
accents how is it automatically racist
if George Floyd was white and the exact
same joke was was told that well then I
guess it wouldn't be racist then you
would just you would say it was in poor
taste
it's personally offensive to George
Floyd his family that's what you would
say you wouldn't say it was racist so
anyway that was over a week ago and the
traumatized students still have not
recovered from this they haven't gotten
over it here's an article on kansas city
calm let me apply I just have to read
some of this too
the headline is I am totally scared
black students dread return to Kansas
State after racist tweets
well I each have to pause right there
dread return after tweet it says Michela
Ross a Kansas City a Kansas State
University sophomore went our internship
boss at ExxonMobil last week and told
him I'm scared to go back to school she
wanted him to know why she couldn't
concentrate on work she was preoccupied
checking in with schoolmates after a
k-state students racially insensitive
tweets about George Floyd offended
students of color and drew support from
national white supremacist groups I'm
not scared to speak out I'm scared of
the unknown said Ross I feel like the
k-state environment is hostile and not
welcoming to black students and our
administration has not taken actionable
measures against racist incidents that
have happened there and this is not the
first one in an unscientific student
poll on Twitter 124 of the approximately
700 black students on the Manhattan
Kabat campus responded to the question
do you feel safe on campus about 80
percent said no they don't and I can't
even continue reading this I just i this
is this is mental illness okay if you
sincerely cannot concentrate on work and
you have to
to your boss about it and you're
traumatized and you're actually scared
to go back to school because a kid
tweeted something that you have a mental
illness you have psychological problems
that are much deeper than than any any
tweet can touch yes you do need
counseling that's the thing that's
that's the one thing I actually agree
with this stuff from the school of us if
you need counseling yeah all all of
these students that are traumatized they
all need counseling but not because of
the tweet just how do you function as a
human being when you are that fragile
that that a tweet that someone sent
could make you could incapacitate you
and on top of that it's it's it's like
it's a tweet and 99% of the people
reacting to it are not just condemning
it but are over-the-top condemning it so
it's not even like you can say you you
feel ganged up on or everyone into the
tweet was said it's a tweet everybody is
saying is a horrible tweet it's the
worst is that not enough is that is that
not enough condemnation if a million
people react to something and all but
like three of them are condemning it is
that still you need the other three to
in order to function again as a person
it's just my god let's go to number two
here and now the great hero the great
martyr Colin Kaepernick has met the Fate
that all great martyrs meet which is a
partnership deal with Disney here's
Kaepernick saying I'm excited for this
partnership with Disney across all of
its platforms to elevate black and brown
directors creators storytellers and
producers I look forward to sharing
culturally impactful and inspiring
projects this is this is a you know I
I can never cease to be impressed and
and just be an admiration of Colin
Kaepernick
and his heroism and self-sacrifice I
want you to think about what this man
did okay he gave up a job as the
mediocre second string quarterback for a
losing franchise he gave that up and all
he got in return was multi-million
dollar partnership deals with some of
the biggest corporations on earth and
widespread media claim that's all he got
that's it we all he got was way more
money Fame admiration than he had before
amazing a true martyr I mean this is
what martyrdom is number three now an
important story from the Daily Caller
it says a German man was hospitalized
Saturday after he was dared to lick a
venomous snake during his bachelor party
in the Australian Alps after the
incident was reported a mountain rescue
operations team and a doctor were called
on the 30 year-old man was taken to a
nearby hospital the local Red Cross
organization stated the man was bit on
the tongue after fellow party goers
dared him to lick the snake you know at
least this is one vestige of toxic
masculinity that we still have and I
cherish it that that men will still do
almost anything if you just say I dare
you to do it that's that's the one thing
and I think we have to we have to hang
on to that at all cost now a report from
The Daily wire it says actress Halle
Berry apologized and backed out of
potentially playing a transgender
character in a film after she received
fierce backlash online for considering
the role as a cisgender woman according
to Harper's Bazaar Berry told fans via
Instagram live that she was up for
consideration to play a transgender man
in an upcoming film until she received a
flood of criticism scolding her for
taking a role from someone who
identifies as transgender and so she's
not going to do that anymore but but so
this is a she was supposed to play a
transgender man so in other words a
female this is a female who was going to
play a female and
is appropriation okay makes a lot of
sense and finally a report from the AAP
it says New York hospitals released more
than 6300 recovering coronavirus
patients into nursing homes during the
height of the pandemic under a
controversial now scrapped policy
according to state officials but so we
knew this was happening we didn't know
the extent of it now they're saying 6300
infected people were sent into nursing
homes but they argued it was they are
not to blame for one of the nation's
highest nursing home death tolls what
they're saying is it's the it's the
staffers who who were infected they're
blaming the staffers just just to just
summarize their rationalization the
saying it's not their fault yes they
sent infected people by mandate by order
into nursing homes into the into the
places where the most vulnerable people
are not their fault though no they're
blaming the staffers just the hubris is
almost unbelievable all right we're
going to go to our daily cancelation but
before we do you know this past weekend
we witnessed a complete and total
mockery of our country and the founding
principles was built on and no I'm not
talking about President Trump speech I'm
talking about the media response to it
it's just the complete and total sham
that's called journalism nowadays this
horror show from the left is exactly the
kind of thing that ben shapiro talks
about in his new book how to destroy
america in three easy steps you can
pre-order your signed copy at delhi
wired.com slash you've been the book
covers two fundamentally different
visions for America that we're facing
right now there's a very important book
for the for our time for this for this
current moment in our culture one vision
finds unity and shared philosophy
culture and history the other
disintegrates our country in the name of
fundamental change
hence disintegration as' these are the
people who use weapons like cancel
culture and force apologies to advance
their agenda Shapiro covers all of this
ground and more in his book how to
destroy America in three easy steps
again you can pre-order your signed copy
at Daley wire.com slash Ben to get the
perfect snapshot of this strange moment
in our history
now speaking of strange moments in our
history this is
another another hallmark of this moment
is the what we do now of sharing
out-of-context videos of people
maliciously in order to destroy them and
this is this is our daily cancelation I
will be cancelling with great prejudice
everyone who maliciously shares out of
context videos in an attempt to ruin the
lives of usually just random people who
are you know random private people and
and despite not having all the facts
we're obviously at a crisis level with
this kind of thing it happens all the
time there are two recent examples I
want to talk about briefly so first we
have some kids who work for Jimmy John's
who've now been fired and publicly
shamed all over the internet and the
media for an admittedly quite dumb video
that they did take themselves and share
themselves but it's a video with with
one of them has a noose made out of
bread dough around his neck and anyway
here's the here's the video
[Music]
you have suspected
now the claim like in this tweet here
from Nick Pappas and by so many others
is that this is racist to racist video
this was done to mock the lynching of
black Americans that's what we're told
but that's not actually what you see in
the video is it
there is nothing racial in the video is
is there was there another video is
there more context to this that gives us
some evidence that this was racially
motivated I don't know we haven't seen
it nobody's mentioned it yes they're
making a joke out of a noose which is
macabre and also an unsanitary use of a
food product which is really the only
thing I'm offended by in the video but
how is it racist and it really matters
because if these are just some kids
being stupid and misusing a food product
and being on sanitary and making a mock
object out of like suicide or something
well then we would all say that's stupid
and yeah they're gonna get fired because
they took the video and they put it up
and again they're you know you can't do
that with the food so any company is
gonna fire you for that but if that's
all it was their whole lives aren't
going to be destroyed probably because
of it but you attach the word racist to
it and you say that they're making fun
of black people being lynched
well now not only do they lose their
Jimmy John's job their whole lives are
destroyed they're forever going to be
the insanely racist people who are
making fun of you know lynching black
people so it really matters whether or
not this was racist and there's no
evidence of that the only evidence
apparently is just that they were making
a joke out of a news out of a fake news
but since when did a noose become a
universal sign of racism nooses and
hanging have been used across the world
everywhere you know as as in order to
kill people this is and it's also the
most one of the most
forms of suicide so this is something
that we're watching the media and the
left do right now in real-time they're
taking the news and they're they're just
they're making it into a white
supremacist symbol even though it isn't
and it never has been
they're just they're making it into that
it's just like they did with the okay
sign but I just did that so now watch
this is gonna be all media matters now
the that symbol which which fur I don't
know decades men a okay good or
something like that the media made it
into a white supremacist symbol and if
you remember there was a guy and now
people are getting fired even if they
just inadvertently make that's a guy a
Hispanic truck driver made that
inadvertently did that while he was
cracking his knuckles he was kind of
like going like this and he got fired as
a suspected white supremacist so now
though the media is doing that with this
as well and these are these are real
people whose lives are being destroyed
and nobody cares and then there's this
video which according to people like
David Levitt shows quote ignorant
Florida man without masks
screams and spreads spit at elderly
woman who asked him to please wear a
mask and the man who defended her
because quote he feels threatened that's
the description of the video sounds
pretty bad here's the actual video okay
wait a second almost nothing in the
description that I just read to you is
actually shown in that video yes a guy
is screaming yes he says he feels
threatened but there's no elderly woman
in sight there's no discussion about
masks you don't see in this video a man
being politely asked to wear masks by an
elderly welder Lee woman and then him
freaking out in response that's not what
you see you see a man
freaking out that's the part you see you
don't see what led up to it you don't
see the context in fact in the video in
this clip anyway the thing that he's
upset about is being filmed and publicly
shamed that's the thing he's mad about
which on that note I don't blame them
for that now maybe the rest of what
David Levitt says did happen but that's
not what you see in the video and so
what happens now is we get these out of
context videos and almost always what we
see is someone reacting to something and
then the people sharing it just fill in
the blanks and tell you and tell you
what what led up to that reaction and
very few people stop to say okay can we
see that part of it how do we know that
what your description of the off-camera
stuff actually happened and by the way
why was this video clip that way there
in that video there's obviously more to
it it cuts on in the middle of so that
it's pretty clear that there's at you
know I don't know is there five seconds
more is there ten minutes I don't know
but for some reason someone decided to
cut out the rest of it and just show us
that part why maybe there's an innocent
explanation but maybe not this is the
game though and it's and I don't know if
this is what happened here but we also
know the game among some agitators is to
provoke a reaction out of somebody and
get the reaction on tape and then make
up a story about what led up to that
reaction to try to destroy the person we
saw that I think we played that video of
you know got black guy who said that he
he tracked down a woman who had shouted
a racial slur at him and you know the
only thing we see in the video is her
outside of her home because she had been
followed back to her house by the guy
and she was scared because a man just
followed her back to her house so I
think she has every right to be scared
and
that we get him filling in the blanks
and just claiming that that he used the
racial slur which even if she did that
wouldn't justify you following her back
to her house but we don't see that part
and that's the game so everybody who
shares these kinds of videos
uncritically and with the malicious
intent to randomly destroy people they
don't know who were involved in a
confrontation that they know nothing
about and the context of which they are
they are ignorant all of those people
are all canceled and we'll leave it
there thanks for watching everybody
thanks for listening Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
our supervising producers are Mathis
Glover and Robert Sterling our technical
producer is Austin Stevens edited by
Dani D'Amico and our audio is mixed by
Robyn Fenderson
the Matt Walsh show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon is
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew clip
[Music]